Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie got new Doctor
Who who series 10 trailer and the Christmas
special.
So let's break it down.
There's gonna be some Sherlock coming up next
week I'll be doing videos for so be sure to
subscribe to get that click that bell to enable
alerts so you don't miss any of the videos.
So I'm going to start with the trailer but
there was this really nice moment during the
Christmas special for the doctors kind of
eulogizing River song from last year's Christmas
special.
So we'll talk a little bit more about that
when I'm breaking down the episode but he
has this really nice speech about how things
and he was mostly talking about River song
dying and just being happy that she was alive
and enjoying the time that he had with her,
but another really nice line from the episode
was this is really getting meta.
So, in a meadow way the doctor is eulogizing
Peter Capaldi's time as the doctor because
the new season that were getting ready for
later this year is going to be his last Doctor
Who who series 10 is supposed to at least
at this point is supposed to be Peter Capaldi's
last season's doctor who and then after that
will recast the role they'll be a new Doctor
Who new show runner because Stephen Moffat
is leaving the series but we can talk about
that when it airs later in the year.
It's not an air for a long time but Pearl
Mackie is going to be the new companion as
you saw in the trailer in addition to providing
comedic relief.
She's also the explainer character like what's
a doll like I don't understand where's the
bathroom in the TARDIS cannot use it.
This looks like a kitchen, just sort of subverting
a lot of the classic tropes of Doctor Who
because of your longtime watcher of Doctor
Who and you try to get your new friends to
watch it you have the exact same problem there.
Just years and years of Doctor Who continuity
in history the you have to make sense of it
really short amount of time.
And even with people like me that have YouTube
channels dedicated to following continuity
and explaining mythology and things like that.
It just turns into a big headache.
So every once in a while you need a new character
like Pearl Mackie's character whose name Bill
to just introduce newer audiences to what
Doctor Who who is in some of the broader concepts.
So her name on the series is going to be Bill
Potts as you can see she's a university student.
Doctor Who play something of the old professor,
which I think Peter Capaldi is perfect for
likely gone for really young anachronistic
versions of the doctor like Matt Smith two
slightly more age-appropriate Peter Capaldi
type doctors just do a better job of reminding
you that the doctor is over 2000 years old.
So that actually reminds me minor correction
Doctor Who who is starting in April, but we
don't know which weekend but it's a Saturday
show so it'll be one of those Saturdays during
April.
I don't know from and to be doing videos for
every single episode but least of the premier
probably do the finale in between that we
can figure that out slightly related.
A lot of you are also asking about Sherlock
yes I am going to be doing Sherlock next week
that starts January 1 the first episode, so
I'll remind everyone when I post my next are
like video but the Christmas special the return
of Doctor Who Mysterio.
So we learned that Doctor Who Mysterio is
not just a chaplain who sort of playing the
superhero of the episode.
It's actually the doctor who he as a child
dubs Doctor Who Mysterio.
So when the episode says the return of Doctor
Who Mysterio, it's the return of Doctor Who
and I think that they chose that title for
meadow reasons because in the context of the
story the doctors been gone for 24 years because
he's been spending all that time with River
song since this moment in the last Christmas
special were she's like it's a shame that
we only have this last night together like
they have one night in their on this foreign
planet and then she's like how long do knights
last on this planet.
He's like oh about 24 years.
So she just laughs because like okay, they
have a lot of time left together but in the
real world.
He's been gone for these past 24 years.
So this young boy has grown up he still has
the superpowers but don't worry.
You know you can enjoy your new life with
your girlfriend here and the baby because
the doctor is back I'll take care of everything.
Doctor Who Mysterio has returned those you
asking about the timeline though.
This is the way it goes.
So you have that moment with River song the
series 9 Christmas finale the husbands of
River song she goes on after that to the silence
in the library that two-part episode dies.
But while she's doing that going off to the
library to have that final adventure with
the David Tennant Doctor Who the 12th Doctor
Who Capaldi is coming back to modern-day.
So in the context of Doctor Who this episode
is happening right after silence in the library
like right after River dies, but the episode
itself was more of a play on the recent trend
of superhero comic book movies so the doctor
made fun of Spider-Man.
There was a bunch of Marvel all over the wallpaper
in his bedroom.
He was reading a Golden age Superman comic,
so a lot of Doctor Who poking fun at superheroes.
So like when they were doing the Clark Kent
Superman stuff in the episode it was really
over the top like it was meant to be very
kitschy it almost played a lot like the energy
of the 90s Dean Cain Superman series just
really on the nose with the humor it almost
didn't feel like a Doctor Who episode because
it was so much American stuff going on inside
of it like this Was Taking Pl. in New York
City instead of in London where it usually
would take place.
But there's a whole bunch of wordplay in like
the first 15 minutes of the episode.
They dropped a ton of Easter eggs like oh
I always get a cold during Christmas and the
doctor says yeah I usually get colds to or
invasions talking about the Christmas invasion.
The very first episode the David Tennant debuted
and then he says my name is the doctor and
he asked him which, Doctor Who argued we have
lots of doctors and he says I'm the original
one, everybody else's copying me.
So he's making fun of Doctor Who strange they're
making fun of all the other previous 12 doctors
like there are a lot of doctors in Doctor
Who but in the world of superheroes.
There's also lots of Doctor Who superheroes
as well.
So the doctors constructing something to fix
all of the time aberrations that have been
happening in New York City New York City itself
has been the setting for many Doctor Who episodes
there was the angel take Manhattan but I think
more pointedly there was the doll X in Manhattan
and then the sequel to that evolution of the
doll X which were actually David Tennant episodes
but New York City itself shows up during many
more Doctor Who adventures going all the way
back to classic Doctor Who.
So the doctors basically saying a lot of crazy
shit has been happening in New York, especially
lately.
I'm trying to fix it.
But then grant eats the jewel it draws upon
the power to give him whatever he wants to
do so he becomes a super hero because he is
obsessed with superheroes like most kids are
the invasion of the body snatchers aliens
that are trying to take over in the episode
are actually new.
They haven't been featured on Doctor Who before
but it's a very invasion of the body snatcher
story where the just trying to replace everyone
with aliens one of the unit soldiers was replaced
at the very end of the episode.
They might follow up on that, during series
10, but there is now another alien working
inside unit in disguise little more nefarious
than Osgood but this isn't the first time
an alien has infiltrated unit they had the
big zygon invasion episode there was the question
of which Osgood remained after series 8 is
the zygon Osgood, is this original human Osgood,
so we'll see what happens with unit during
series 10 the whole brains in jars reminded
me of Futurama just like head sitting in jars
on shelves together as well as the headless
monks speaking of headless Nardo comes back
from the previous Christmas special that was
the River song story that they kept referencing
at the end of this episode, so he's a human
cyborg.
That's where the doctor said I put you back
together you have to do what I say.
So he's helping the doctor out probably till
he picks up Bill here at University she becomes
the new companion let me know in the comments
what you guys excited for in series 10 who
do you want to come back, it sounds like they're
trying to reintroduce a lot of classic things
through the bill character and explain it
for new audiences like look at all this awesome
stuff we have.
So I would expect a lot of deep cuts along
with a bunch of new stuff mixed in showing
up the whole breadth of Doctor Who history
in a way that new people can understand.
So I will say the Christmas episode.
Probably not my favorite I like the River
song Christmas episode last year little bit
better, but I tend to like the more serious
Doctor Who stories with a little bit of comedy
in them more than the lighthearted stories
like this one with a little bit of serious
stuff in them like they really only got serious
at the very end when the doctors basically
saying that things and should be happy for
the time that we have with them.
Basically like I said eulogizing River song
saying that she's dead now and also saying
that Peter Capaldi is going to be leaving
Doctor Who soon it's kind of sad but everything
ends they make way for new exciting things
to begin.
Just letting you know it's gonna be sad that
Capaldi is in around anymore but will have
somebody new would be really exciting.
So I wouldn't expect them to announce that
till towards the end of Doctor Who who series
10, but they probably know who the next Doctor
Who is already so get hype were still on Justice
league trailer watch there's gonna be couple
of the big trailers dropping in the next couple
days there still some marvel DC stuff.
I'll be doing and some Sherlock that I'll
be posting next week so look out for that
what you guys wait for that to post you can
click here to rewatch the alien covenant video
and you can click here for my breakdown of
the latest Justice league teaser.
Thank you so much watching everybody thought
you guys tonight!